heute gibt's ein blitzschnelles BG
Rezept aus der
[Musik]
Pfanne das ist halt so ein Last Minute
Rezept wenn es mal richtig schnell gehen
muss und weil das Rezept so schnell geht
werde ich jetzt erstmal die Beilage dazu
machen Beilage ist bisschen komisch den
Tee dafür zubereiten es gibt nämlich
Schwarztee dazu ganz klassisch machen
wir einmal kurz Schwarztee setzen den
auf und während der durchzieht ist das
BG auch schon fertig ja so machen wir
das komm mal mit d einfach unseren
Schwarztee das er dieser Schwarztee mit
den Blättern und den nehmt ihr jetzt
einfach und füllt drei Esslöffel davon
in die obere Porzellankanne das ganze
wird dann ausgewaschen dann kommt in die
untere emanne etwas Wasser und dieses
wird zum Kochen gebracht und dann habe
ich später hier unten drin nämlich das
heiße Wasser das hält auch den Tee warm
und oben drauf habe ich dann den Tee
also als Konzentrat der Tee kann jetzt
etwa 15 Minuten Zehen und ich kann mein
bdck zubereiten ich zeig euch mal die
Zutaten ich verwende dafür hier diese
jufka Teig Blätter sage ich gleich was
dazu dann habe ich hier etwas Käse
nämlich einmal einen Hirtenkäse einen
kashchkavalkäse also der schmilzt halt
einfach extrem gut ein Ei hier habe ich
jeweils 220 g Wasser das ist
Sprudelwasser 200 g Milch Salz und
Pfeffer und etwas Olivenöl da nehme ich
jetzt mein knoblaucholivenöl die
jufkablätter die bekommt ihr einfach im
türkischen Supermarkt oder in gut
sortierten Supermärkten und da gibt's
verschiedene da gibt's so ganz dünne die
habe ich jetzt hier die kann man auch
für bulover verwenden ihr könnt aber
wirklich jede Art von jufgteig nehmen
und ich hatte mal ein pfannenbck gemacht
aber das hier ist noch mal ein Tick
schneller also da kommen jetzt erstmal
die Flüssigkeiten rein das Ei Milch und
Wasser bisschen mit Salz und Pfeffer
würzen dann verrühren ich habe jetzt
hier den Käse einfach auch schon mal
zerkleinert das heißt ich habe einmal
den Hirtenkäse ihr könnt auch Schafskäse
nehmen und den kashchkwall dann gebe ich
die Kräuter noch dazu die könnt ihr
frisch oder gefroren nehmen und jetzt
jetzt kommt
normalerweise wird es dann darin
geschichtet wir machen es aber richtig
einfach ich schneide den einfach in
Streifen jetzt könnt den so ein bisschen
auseinander nehmen damit auch gleich
überall Füllung dran kommt denn so muss
man sagen es sfgar schon recht trocken
wenn man den nicht unbedingt selbst
macht ist dann wie so eine Art
pfannenlasagne halt mit Käse statt mit
Hackfleisch das gibt jetzt einfach da
rein
es sieht alles extrem falsch aus aber es
ist nicht falsch jetzt einfach schön
verrühren zu einer großen Match Pumpe
sozusagen so dass überall Flüssigkeit
ist und eine größere Schüssel nehmen
können ich muss
sagen ich muss sagen die Größe der
Schüssel passt perfekt die hätte nicht
größer sein dürfen guckt mal das S am
Anfang vielleicht nach ganz viel aus
aber es fällt h ja zusammen es ist
einfach perfekt K vielleicht sowas
einblenden so wenn Sie die
Schlüsselgröße richtig gewählt hat dass
S dann auch ein Punkt kriegt so
Bingo richtig
[Musik]
geschätzt die Masse ist jetzt fertig und
jetzt nehmt ihr euch am besten eine
beschichtete Pfanne ich habe hier meine
wbenpfanne mit der funktioniert es prima
die wird kurz gefettet mit etwas
Olivenöl nehmen auch
knoblaucholivenöl
was soll's ich brauche noch kurz einen
Pinsel der ist
hier dann ein fetten trotzdem auch wenn
die Pfanne gut beschichtet ist aber das
sorgt einfach auch dafür dass ich eine
schöne Kruste bekomme man kann da auch
echt immer super so eine restewertung
machen und praktisch wenn man
Frühlingszwiebel noch hat oder bisschen
Lauch oder bisschen Gemüse einfach mit
reinschnibbeln das sieht ja am Ende
keiner alles was euch schmeckt darf
jetzt hier mit rein jetzt
einfüllen verteilen wir das so bisschen
und drücken fl aber nicht so fest und
kompakt denn ich will nicht dass es so
eine feste kompakte Masse ergibt sondern
schon trotzdem ein leckeres lockeres BG
wird und dann gebe ich jetzt hier den
Deckel drauf stell das ganze auf
mittelhohe Hitze also bei mir geht der
Herd bis 9 ich würde mal so zwischen 5hb
und und jetzt lassen wir das erstmal so
ungefähr 10 Minuten backen das ist die
perfekte Zeit um hier aufzuräumen dann
wird's einmal gewendet und das schon
fertig
Tee ist gleich soweit
und auch ich guck mal kurz
drunter ma mal einmal
gemeinsam so schön also normalerweise
wenn ich jetzt richtig lustig drauf W
würde ich ja so wenden aber da wäre mir
jetzt die Verbrennungsgefahr zu groß
denn das hat ja ein ordentliches Gewicht
wenn ich das jetzt umdrehe dann spritzt
das Fett ma nicht machen wir nicht das
ist zu gefährlich also nehme ich jetzt
einfach entweder den großen Teller oder
eine einen tortenretter auch bdretter
genannt ein Z
hoppala nein warte das darf nicht
verrutschen
so okay wow guckt euch mal an wie schön
und jetzt wieder zurück
sehr gut also das waren jetzt so
ungefähr 10 Minuten und jetzt machen wir
noch mal so 3 bis 4
Minuten bis es auch schön goldbraun auf
der Seite ist ja dann sind wir fertig
wie versprochen ein super leichtes
Rezept jetzt ist es
fertig muss sagen riecht schon richtig
gut und sieht gut aus perfekt dann Sch
hen wir doch direkt mal Tee
ein also wie gesagt das ist ein
Konzentrat oben dann gebt ihr so viel
rein wie Ihr möchtet und dann kommt
heißes Wasser dazu zack am besten ohne
klackern okay und das burdg jetzt
hier zum
Schneiden das sieht gut aus okay wir
testen
und ja sieht gut
aus schmeckt gut könnt nachmachen
schmeckt super das ist auf jeden Fall
ein Rezept was ihr daheim ausprobieren
könnt meine Mama wird auch lieben denn
es geht super schnell man kann es ganz
schnell vorbereiten die Zutaten hab
immer zu Hause und ihr könnt gerne
nachlesen auf
sbogde dann hat machen wir jetzt gleich
mal wieder an denn der Tee muss bisschen
weiter kochen und warm bleiben und ihr
könnt das Rezept auch gerne in der App
nachlesen und wenn es euch gefällt dann
schreibt gerne drunter also viel Spaß
beim Nachmachen bis zum nächsten Mal und
am Sonntag am Sonntag ist sie endlich da
am Sonntag ist malwanne bei mir in der
Küche wir haben es geschafft sie war
zwar nicht hier im Studio wir haben es
nämlich noch in der anderen Küche
gedreht aber sie ist da und kurzzeitig
gibt's vielleicht bisschen beef zwischen
uns aber erfahrt ihr dann am
Sonntag
tschüss
so mal
en